Das Podcast Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo, Ufo,witzt. Wir haben richtig mitgetanzt, richtig abgezappelt zu diesem absoluten Banger, den Dennis hier aus den Klaviertasten gezaubert hat. Dennis! Ich glaube, man sagt, bei dieser Musik kriege ich nicht mehr tanzen, aber würde ich mir jetzt nicht aus dem Fenster lehnen.
Ich glaube, man sagt dann pogen.
Man ist immer zu cool geworden als Musikrichtung, als Genre,
um zu tanzen noch dazu.
Ich glaube, auch bei einem Linking-Park
oder Green-Day-Konzert sagt man jetzt nicht,
ich habe ordentlich getanzt.
Habt ihr schön getanzt? Ja, wir haben schön getanzt.
Ich glaube, man sagt eher, wart ihr im Moshpit? Ja, wir haben gepoggt.
Das stimmt, wir haben einen schönen Gruppentanz, wir haben gepogen und ja, finde ich gut, danke fürs Pogen, danke schön an Dennis, ungelogen, gut gepogen, finde ich richtig gut gemacht, Dennis. Er hat sich nicht verbogen. Er hat sich nicht verbogen, wir müssen uns vielleicht verbiegen, weil, ich sag mal so, heute wird keine gute Laune Folge, wir müssen natürlich heute mit großer Intensität die Mundwinkel nach oben reißen. Wir haben uns gerade schon gestritten auch. Wir haben uns gerade schon gestritten, wir sind beide am Boden, glaube ich, beide aus unterschiedlichen Gründen. Heute wird eine Leitklagen-Folge, also wir werden uns jetzt eine Stunde lang gegenseitig unser Leit klagen, weil das muss auch mal sein. Wir laden aber auch alle mit, auch das Leit zu klagen. Ja. Jetzt nicht mit Mails oder in Direktnachrichten bei Instagram, bitte nicht, aber so generell könnt ihr ja Leid klagen. Behindert euch daran. Tut einfach so, als würdet ihr telefonieren in der Öffentlichkeit. Legt einfach euer Handy so ans Ohr und tut so, als würdet ihr irgendjemandem das Leid klagen, aber es kommt nirgendwo an. Genau, wir haben ja letzte Woche darüber gesprochen. Wir haben ja auch ein Punching-Bag und es ist die Frage, was kann auch ausgedacht sein, ein Punching-Bag. Wir haben letzte Woche über neue App-Ideen gesprochen und du hattest die tolle Idee auf Grundlage von Sleepover, dass man zufällig anderen Leuten zugeordnet wird, mit denen man reden kann. Und du, Stefan, hattest die geniale Idee, dass man nicht anderen Menschen, sondern anderen Tieren verbunden wird. Nee, das war deine Idee. Kann auch vielleicht meine Idee gewesen sein. Und wir haben eine Mail bekommen von jemandem, der hat Pfau und sagt, er wäre bereit, Telefonpfau abzustellen. Also ein kleines Telepfau-Center, wo einfach viele an so ganz... Oder Pauderphone, kann man nicht, also finde ich ganz gut, Pauderphone finde ich ganz gut eigentlich. Wo die so ganz windige Headsets haben und einfach den ganzen Tag am Aperillo sitzen und auch mal ihr Futter hart erarbeiten müssen im Callcenter. Und ihr könnt Pfau anrufen und denen euer Leid klagen. Jetzt wird diese ganze Kommunikation wieder wahnsinnig durcheinander. Unsere Idee war ja quasi, entspannten Waldklängen zu lauschen. Slash, Geocaching, man findet dieses Mikrofon, nimmt eine Tröte mit und ballert Leute aus dem Schlaf. So, in der Verlängerung. Hört euch die letzte Folge an. Ja, es ist in der Verlängerung. Aber das ist jetzt so eine Leitklage. Weil meine Idee war einfach nur, dass man miteinander spricht, quasi im Flüsterton. Weil das waren die spannendsten Gespräche meines Lebens. Dinge, die nach dem Gute-Nacht-Sagen passiert sind. Ja, in dieser zauberhaften Phase, wo schon Gute-Nacht gesagt wurde. Der Tag ist vorbei. Der Tag wurde abmoderiert. Ja, aber es ist auch noch nicht Nacht, wenn man noch nicht schläft. Es ist diese Limbo, diese Zwischenzeit, wo niemand genau weiß, wo man ist. Wo alles ist erlaubt. Da wurden Dinge gesagt, die man, die aber nicht gelten. Am nächsten Tag war da nicht, weil es war ja nicht gestern, wann wurde es gesagt? Niemand kann diesen Zeitpunkt benennen, wo es gesagt wurde und Und dadurch entzieht sich ja dessen jegliche Realität.
Ich mag ja immer sehr gerne die Geschichte von unserer geschätzten Kollegin Katjana Gerz, die bei einer solchen Sleepover-Party dabei war und die ihre Freundinnen anscheinend dachten, sie würde schon schlafen und die im Flüsterton angefangen haben, über sie zu lästern, sie aber noch wach war. Das ist schon eigentlich bitter. Also das kann auch nach hinten losgehen. Das Schlimmste, was mir passiert ist, hat mich auch ziemlich geprägt, ist, ich habe bei einer Sleepover-Party, wo Leute miteinander geschlafen haben, nachdem Gute Nacht gesagt wurde. Oh nein! Ja, und ich habe es mitbekommen. Und das war wirklich grauenhaft. Aber wie viele Leute waren im Raum? Ich möchte nicht so wahnsinnig viele Details dazu beantworten. Mehrere Leute waren im Raum und aber auch hier kann man sauer sein auf diese Leute, weil nach meiner eigenen Logik, da habe ich mir ein bisschen Beingestellt, argumentativ selber, ist es nicht passiert, ist es in einem Limbo passiert. Ja, das stimmt, das ist rechtlich nicht gültig. Wenn ich das jetzt dem Richter, der Richterin vortrage, als das geht ja wohl nicht, gesellschaftlich, dann hätte die Richterin, der Richter mir dann meine Sachen vorgetragen, die ich gesagt habe in diesem Limbo und dann, weißt du? Oh, wie unangenehm. Aber eben auch was für ein Selbstbewusstsein, oder einfach zu sagen, in einer gut befüllten Schlafhalle. Ich weiß ja nicht, was das für eine Schlafsituation war, aber ganz unangenehm. Das ist ein unangenehmes Moment meines Lebens.
Und du warst in eine der beiden Personen verliebt wahrscheinlich und hast dann stillschweigend.
Tatsächlich war es ein bisschen so, ja.
Oh nein!
Und es war das Schlimmste der Welt.
Oh Gott, vor allem du kannst ja der Situation auch nicht entfliehen.
Du kannst ja nicht einfach sagen, du gehst in der Mitte einfach raus und sagst, Leute, ich bin raus, weil du musst ja so tun, als würdest du schlafen.
Anders kommst du ja nicht durch diesen Moment durch.
Nee, du kommst nicht raus, du bist gefangen. Das ist das Schlimmste, was man jemandem antun kann. Ja, aber niemand der beiden wusste das ja. Und das ist halt das Schlimme daran. Also das war ein grauenhafter Moment und so. Und daran seht ihr mal, ich wollte das eigentlich nie erzählen. Ach, Steffen. Aber es ist genau, heute ist die Leidklagen-Folge, heute erzählen wir Dinge, sehr persönliche Dinge. Und das ist wirklich eine Geschichte, die mich sehr beeinflusst hat, glaube ich. Und da seht ihr mal, was dann hinter so einem Gag, den man dann mal so raushaut, steckt eigentlich für ein Trauma. Ja, zwischen so einem billigen V-Wort-Spiel, da eigentlich noch dahinter steckt. Nee, meine Sleepover-Idee von letzter Woche, dahinter steckt nämlich eigentlich ein längst verdrängtes Trauma. Ja, stimmt, du hättest in dem Moment jemanden gebraucht, mit dem du auch noch flüstern kannst. Ja, oder für mich ist dann, weißt du, ich habe ja quasi, indem ich gesagt habe, diese Zeit, diese Limbo-Zeit ist die wichtigste und weil die so, weil die nichts zählt, ist ja nur Verdrängungsmechanismus. Rückgängig versucht, es ungeschehen zu machen. Genau. Okay. Wow, ja, nicht schlecht. Jetzt erzähl deine Top 3, die Top 3 Dinge, die unser Leben nachhaltig beeinflusst haben. Also auf jeden Fall, es gibt jetzt die Möglichkeit eines Pfauenservice, könnt ihr anrufen und den Leid klagen. Warum nicht? Warum nicht? Wir haben ehrlich gesagt, warum wirklich nicht? Oder ist das dann Tierquälerei oder so? Ich glaube, es kommt darauf an. Ich glaube, Callcenter arbeiten ist für Menschen schon schwer zugänglich. Ich habe ja auch lange im Callcenter gearbeitet. Tieren würde ich das auf jeden Fall nicht raten. Aber Tiere können ja ganz gut zuhören, sagt man ja vielen Tieren nach. Ja. V-Weiß ich jetzt nicht. Weiß ich auch nicht. Was muss man denen sagen, damit die raten? Ja, arroganter Gockel sagt man halt oft nach einem V. Aber ob das dann auf der anderen Ebene ist. Es gibt manche Tiere, zudem gibt es keine Klischees und Vorteile. Also der Fuchs ist schlau, der Elch ist im Weg, die Katze ist irgendwie süss und schnurrt, aber viele Tiere halt auch einfach nichts. Entschuldigung, mein Name ist Guido der Elch, ich wollte gerade fragen, was Sie da gerade gesagt haben, wir stehen im Weg? Elche stehen im Weg, ja, dafür seid ihr bekannt. Nee, aber eigentlich haben wir ja letzte Woche diese neue Marketingkampagne gelaunt, dass Elche schnell sind und clever. Ja. Wir kommen jetzt nicht einigen, deswegen haben wir auch den Kommunikationsschwerpunkt ein bisschen verkackt, gebe ich zu und so, aber im Weg verstehe ich es nicht. Ja, die Kampagne habe ich gesehen, aber die stösst natürlich auch ein bisschen auf taube Ohren, weil oft auch ein Elch im Weg steht, um diese Kampagne zu sehen.
Dieses riesige Geweih, dieser wulstige, schwerige Körper. Nennen Sie drei Beispiele, wo wir im Weg stehen. Ich meine, wir wohnen hier im verschneiden Kanada, ist ja ein großes Land, da kann man ja auch außen rum gehen. Also wann stehen wir denn mal im Weg? Kurze Frage, wie viele von deinen Verwandten wurden von Autos überfahren? Na gut, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wo der Zusammenhang besteht, weil natürlich viele. Ja, die Autos fahren ja nicht irgendwo, Die fahren ja nicht einfach wild im Wald rum, sondern die fahren auf diesen, vielleicht schon mal aufgefallen, grauen Flachwürmern, die sich da durch die Hunde ziehen. Ja, das ist uns aufgefallen. Genau, und da ist euch nicht in meinen Sinne gekommen, euch nicht genau da hinzustellen. Aber das ist so schön glatt. Ja, aber aus einem guten Grund. Und warm, da ist nicht so ein Schnee. Glatt ist gefährlich. Ihr seid eben, geht mir, Entschuldigung. Nee, was, warum wollen Sie jetzt da durch? Warum wollen Sie jetzt genau hier durch? Können Sie einen Schritt zur Seite gehen? Entschuldigung, dieses riesige... Neue Kampagne für die Menschen, sie wollen immer genau da lang, wo man steht. Ja, nein, aber als ob diese scheiß Geweih braucht. Wer sind denn eure Gegner, die ihr kämpfen mit dem Geweih? Menschen sind Nacktköpfe, die immer da durch wollen, wo man steht. Jetzt wird es eine Negativkampagne, jetzt wird es albern. Geh aus dem fucking Weg, geh aus dem fucking Weg, dann habt ihr das Problem auch nicht mehr. Aber es gibt auch andere Tiere, die haben einfach keine Eigenschaft. V-we weiss man nichts drüber. Nee, null. Strausser auch so, klar, schnellste Tier pro Bein. Fliegt nicht. Fliegen nicht leider. Rennen, rennen mit ihren strammen Oberschenkeln, ratzfatz rennen weg, aber wovor rennen sie eigentlich weg? Vor ihren eigenen Problemen. Ich habe auch massive Probleme, ich werde gejagt, ich werde gehetzt. Von Straussen? Mittlerweile, nee, ich werde, ich habe tatsächlich heute einen harten Tag erlebt, nicht nur meine Lieblingsdoter-Mannschaft verloren, kommen wir gleich noch dazu, sondern ich werde Ja bitte,, lass es vielleicht ausführlichkehren zu kommen. Ja, weil du eine Augengratze aufgelachtet haben. Weil ich werde angegriffen, ich werde bombardiert aus dem Cyberspace. Der Cyberspace ist hinter mir her. Der Cyberspace ist in Gänze hinter dir her. In Gänze hinter mir her. Hacker jagen mich von Website zu Website hinter mir her. Kaum eine Ecke im Internet kann ich sicher umgehen, als dass nicht mehrere Cybertäter dahinter auftauchen würden. Ich werde verfolgt. Hast du schon die Kapuze aufgesetzt, also ein VPN? Ich glaube, es gibt einen VPN, der heißt einfach Kapuze. Und wenn ich mir gut, wenn es ein VPN geht, einfach Kapuze. Dieen alle irgendwie Cyberghost, finde ich auch nicht schlecht. Cyberghost finde ich gut. ExpressVPN finde ich boring, boring as fuck. Aber Kapuze? Das finde ich eine gute Möglichkeit. Kapuze ist eigentlich für einen Hacker, Kapuze ist eigentlich das Hacker-Zeichen. Ja, wer benutzt denn VPNs? Okay. Aber jetzt habe ich eine Frage, weil ich habe gerade zu Hause, weil du den Termin verschoben hast, weil deine Lieblingsmannschaft gespielt hat, hast du den Aufnahmetermin verschoben, ist so ein Fenster, so ein Vakuum bei mir entstanden. Das habe ich gefüllt mit einer Doku, die ich immer schon mal schauen wollte, die Wirecard-Doku. Ah ja. Und da ging es auch oft darum, dass gerade auch Investigativjournalisten oder Whistleblower, die wurden vom Cyberspace verfolgt. Da bei denen verstehe ich das, warum die verfolgt wurden. Warum wirst du verfolgt? Anscheinend wollen Leute an mein Geld ran. Jetzt auch bei Wirecard verstehe ich, warum man hinter denen eher will. Wir haben auch alle viel Geld. Nein, ich weiß nicht, ob es so schlau ist, das öffentlich zu sagen, aber ich bin eh schon im Visier, von daher glaube ich, kann ich es nicht noch schlimmer machen, als meine unerträgliche Situation gerade ist. Nein, aber meine, ich wurde heute angerufen und es hieß, jemand versucht, ihr Konto zu hacken. Bitte machen wir sie was dagegen. Tut, tut, tut. Und ich dachte, okay, jetzt gehe ich zum Gegenangriff, jetzt wird zurückgehackt und relativ erfolglos geblieben. Und ja. Kam Warnanruf und die Stelle? Ich bin ja immer super skeptisch, weil ich glaube, womit die meisten Hacker Geld verdienen, ist, dass zu behaupten, man wurde gehackt. Also der klassische Scammer ruft ja an und sagt, oh, sie wurden gehackt, wir müssen es rückgängig machen, geben Sie mal mal Ihr Passwort, damit ich das reparieren kann oder was auch immer. Und dann wird man erst richtig gehackt. Das heißt, ich bin immer sehr skeptisch, wenn jemand anruft und sagt, Sie werden gerade gehackt und ich sage, wo sind Sie denn gerade, in welcher Stadt? Und weil ich immer gelernt habe, man sagt nie Ja sagen, bei solchen skeptischen Anrufen, bei solchen Anrufen, nie Ja sagen, weil dann schneiden die das an eine Frage, wollen sie das und das kaufen. Ja, genau. Und deswegen bin ich immer so eine Art Tabuspiel und rede sehr weird, weil ich immer aus, also ich denke immer, nichts von dem, was ich sage, darf man jemals zusammenschneiden können, als dass es eine bejahrende Aussage hat. Deswegen sage ich sehr oft Nein, mitten im Satz und mache viele Pausen und rede generell seltsam. Kann man so oder so sehen, kommt drauf an. Ja, sowas machen streuen. Ich bin sehr vage. Ja, und ja, ich bin jetzt in einem Cyberkrieg, Cyberwar gefangen, gegen wen auch immer es auf mich abgesehen hat. Aber hast du es dann gemerkt, quasi online schon mal? Nee, ich war völlig blindlings, wurde ich erwischt und jetzt
bin ich zu einem, ja, ich sehe das
als Duell-Herausforderung. Also da hat jemand den
Cyber-Handschuh mir vor die Füsse geworfen
und ich nehme an. Also wer auch immer das ist,
bitte zum 1-v-1-Cyber-Battle.
Und mit welchen Waffen willst du
zurückschießen? Den
stärksten Waffen, die mein Arsenal
zu bieten hat. Welche starken Waffen? Ich bin bis
an die Zähne bewaffnet. Mit stumpfen Internetseiten. Ich hab Textedit offen, ich hab Safari am Start, also, ich sag mal, Mail, hab ich ein paar Hotkeys drauf. Outlook oder Mail? Mail. Ja, Mail. Und also, du wirst nicht wissen, was dich getroffen hat, ich hab fucking Adobe Flash Player auf dem neuesten Stand. Okay, mega. Also, passt mal. VLC auf Lautstärke 300%. Oh ja, Winrar ist installiert. Und also, du wirst dich wundern, was dich da getroffen hat, mein Lieber. Ich gehe zum Gegenangriff über. Diese verdammten Hacker, wir können uns nicht von denen unser Leben ruinieren. Du bist wie die Ewoks auf Endor. Das Einzige, was du hast, sind so Dinge, die um dich herumliegen.
Und am Ende gewinnst du und alle fragen sich, how the fuck?
Ja, weil die Person zu mir kommt.
Er kämpft auf meinem Planeten, auf meinem Endor.
Da bin ich zu Hause.
Der Cyberspace ist meine Welt.
Ich bin da drin.
Ich kann da schwimmen wie ein Fisch.
Ich glaube, er kann besser schwimmen wie ein Fisch.
Fishing-Mail und so weiter. Heute ist eine leidklagende Folge, wo wir so viele Gags erwarten. Aber in der Wildcard-Doku wurde eine Whistleblowerin, das war eine Investitivjournalistin, die hat dann Mails bekommen, weird Mails, Fishing-Angriffe und so. Und einmal ging in der Nacht bei ihr der Drucker an und hat ganz viele Seiten ausgedruckt mit Nachrichten an sie. Was so in etwa das Schlimmste ist, was ich mir vorstellen kann. So schon mal, wo du wohnst, alleine irgendwo. Fuck, die Druckertinte ist ... Und dann die Druckertinte, wie kriegst du jetzt neue Druckertinte? Das ist wirklich das Gemeinste, was man jemandem antun kann, die Druckerpatronen leer drucken zu lassen. Wo du denkst, come on, ey, wirklich stichen mir die Reifen kaputt oder wirf einen Stein durchs Fenster. Er schießt mich, meinetwegen, aber wirklich, aber ich zahl's nicht 39, 99 in irgendeinem scheiß Copyshop, wo ich hingehen muss. Nee, ey, das ist wirklich das Schlimmste, was er machen kann. Ja, und halt der Inhalt auf den Seiten, aber you get the idea. Aber das war ja tatsächlich im Zeitalter des Fax ein beliebter Angriff,
dass du auf Täterseite
hast du so ein
schwarzes Blatt Papier,
also das malst du mit Edding an
und das steckst du in dein
Faxgerät rein und
verbindest es dann mit der anderen Seite des
Blatts, also du hast so ein langes Blatt, das ist wie so ein
Kreis. Frage, machst du nicht deine Eddings
einfach nur leer und des anderen Menschen Tinte?
Ja, das ist genau, das ist die Frage, du tauscht
Tinte gegen Tinte. Ja genau, das ist wie so ein Kreis. Frage, machst du nicht deine Eddings einfach nur leer und des anderen Menschen Tinte?
Ja, das ist genau, das ist die Frage. Du tauscht Tinte gegen Tinte. Ja, genau, das ist wie ein Währungsrechner. Edding gegen Tinte, ja. Genau, was ist teurer? Edding oder Tinte? Aber dann schickst du es ab und dadurch, dass das ja unendlich lange das Fax durchgeht und du halt mit fünf Seiten Papier, bist du unendlich viele Seiten Papier auf der anderen Seite verschwendest, Du schickst es dann an eine Konkurrenzfirma, das Fax, dieses unendlich lange Fax und druckst denen da die Druckertinte leer und das ist natürlich fies. Und so wurden damals im grossen Dotcom-Bubble natürlich viele Firmen in den Bankrott quasi gedruckt. Also, hatte Zeit. Wie ein Prank, den wir immer im Informatikunterricht gemacht haben,
wo wir Kunden ein Virus schreiben,
so per HTML,
der immer ein Fenster neu öffnet und wieder öffnet, wieder öffnet,
wieder öffnet, wieder öffnet, wieder öffnet.
Diese typische Schlange,
aus diesen Fehlermeldungen, die kommen.
Und dieses Programm,
was das macht, das ist eine unendliche
Schleife, die sich selber wiederholt, haben wir genannt GTA5.exe und haben sie auf den Server hochgeladen, wo alle in reingehen mussten. Und wir sassen ganz hinten in der Reihe und es war fantastisch, weil du siehst ja, man hat ja alle Bildschirme gesehen und alle mussten auf diesen Server gehen, um dann da ein Programm zu installieren, was der Lehrer vorne hochgeladen hat. Das heißt, alle mussten entweder auf das Programm klicken, was sie machen sollten, oder rechts daneben ist halt Magically GTA 5.exe entstanden. Und dann haben wir uns so gefragt, okay, jetzt installiere das Programm bitte. und dann saßen wir hinten und haben geguckt, was passiert jetzt? Und auf allen Rechnern kam halt diese Schlange aus dieser Fehlermeldung. Und wir wussten, alle haben sich nicht daran gehalten. Wir haben natürlich schön auf das richtige Programm gekriegt. Und dann ist der Lehrer so richtig reingegangen, was ist bei euch denn überall los? Und dann mussten die alle den Rechner neu starten. Was nicht schlimm ist, du Cyberprankster, Stefan Tietze, der Hacker, das ist ja Wahnsinn. Du hast wirklich schon jede Phase durchgemacht. Du warst schon mal Hacker, warst Feuerwehrmann, Neumfrau. Ich saß primär daneben, in dieser Geschichte war ich primär daneben. Ah ja, Komplize. Und war einfach nur Komplize. Und der andere konnte es umsetzen, und ich habe gesagt, lass es doch einfach, dass die das ausschalten müssen. Nicht schlecht, ey. Du bist eigentlich auf der Feindseite gerade. Also bist du noch Hacker? Ich bin dein Hacker. Wirklich? Versuchst du dich in mich reinzuhaken? Nee, ich bin der Anrufer gewesen, der versucht hat, dich zu warnen. Ja. Das ist die Frage. Irgendwann musst du als Hacker entscheiden, bist du White Hacker oder Black Hacker oder bist du Grey? Weil diese White Hacker, die ja eigentlich so dieser Chaos-Computer-Club-Welt, die ja eigentlich dann ... Die aber Hacker heißen. Die Hacker heißen. Da kann man genau den Unterschied ziehen. Aber ich habe neulich, letzte Woche saß ich zu Hause und habe lange darüber nachgedacht. Ich habe mich einfach hingesetzt in die Wohnung und musste darüber nachdenken, weil mir ist eingefallen,
klar, damals gab es Faxgeräte,
damals gab es vielleicht sogar davor
noch einfach nur Schreibmaschinen,
Leute haben lange für ihre Jobs gebraucht.
Was hatten die für eine Stundenwoche?
Ich würde behaupten, dass
die durchschnittliche Arbeitszeit
einer Woche damals, so in den
60ern, 70ern
genau die gleiche Stundenanzahl war, die wir jetzt haben. Warum? Wir sind doch viel schneller in dem, was wir machen. Und dann dachte ich mir, das ergibt eigentlich, das kannst du ja niemandem eigentlich erklären. Warum sollte jemals sagen, ja klar arbeite ich noch 40 Stunden mit meinen tollen technischen Möglichkeiten. Spätestens seit der Einführung von Mails oder so, jetzt dann im nächsten Schritt halt Slack oder so, müsstest du ja sagen, so, aber jetzt sind es nur noch 30 Stunden die Woche, weil ich spare ja effektiv Zeit. Ja, oder weniger Mitarbeiter machen denn den ganzen Job und die Mitarbeiter, die rausfliegen, werden dann TikTok-Stars. Wo kommen die denn alle her? Twitch-Stars, Twitch-Fame, die müssen ja auch irgendwo herkommen. Es gibt ja neue Jobs jetzt mittlerweile. Siehstste, ich war noch nicht fertig, darüber nachzudenken. Die müssen ja auch jemand machen. Die ganzen Influencer oder so, die kann es nur geben, weil durch die Technologie Arbeitsplätze frei geworden sind. Und die werden jetzt alle TikTok-Stars. Meine Theorie war eher, dass wir gemeinschaftlich vergessen haben, irgendwann mal zu sagen, sorry, ich bin schon fertig und kann ich jetzt nach Hause gehen. Ach so, klar können Sie nach Hause gehen. Nee, man ist ja eher nett und höflich und setzt seine Zeit ab. Und meine Theorie war, es hat einfach noch niemand zugegeben, schon fertig zu sein. So sehr in der Gesamtheit, dass man sagt, wir arbeiten einfach zu lang. Ja, stimmt. Es gibt bestimmt Firmen da draußen, wo 160 Leute arbeiten,
wo eigentlich eine Person die Arbeit macht
und alle anderen einfach nur sitzen und Blätter hin und her reichen
und Sachen ausfüllen, eddingen und schicken Mails und alles.
Ja, auch hier Wirecard.
Ich meine, die einen haben an diesem grossen Betrug gearbeitet.
Was haben denn die anderen in dem Unternehmen,
die ja wirklich dachten, sie hätten normale Jobs effektiv gemacht? Völlig irrelevante Sachen. Und dann stelle ich mir vor, du arbeitest 20 Jahre in einem Unternehmen, da kommt raus, es war alles ein Riesenbetrug und die haben keine Umsätze generiert und du warst aber in dieser eigenen Abteilung da lange drin und bist jeden Morgen zur Arbeit gegangen, hast dich über den Chef aufgeregt und sowas. Ich meine, das muss ja so sehr an dir rütteln, an deiner ganzen Existenz, weil du hast ja nichts gemacht. Ja, oder du denkst dir, warum war ich nicht Teil von den Betrügern? Warum haben die mir das nicht erzählt? Warum haben die mich nicht gefragt, ob ich dabei sein will? Ich wusste, ich wollte mehr zu denen gehören. Ja, im Ende schon. Das war, weil ich damals dieses Croissant.
Ich wollte das Geld wiederhaben. Verdammt nochmal. Ich hatte
lange Zeit eine Wirecard-Prepaid-Kreditkarte.
Echt? Eine Kreditkarte,
wo du prepaid vorhin Geld darauf
überweisen konntest. Tatsächlich, ich glaube,
so ein Problem, das sich durch mein ganzes
Leben zieht, ist, ich will
Dinge kaufen, kann aber nicht.
Im Sinne von amerikanischer
iTunes-Store, HBO Now, irgendwelche Dinge, die ich schlicht, wo ich das Geld habe, aber es einfach nicht kaufen kann. Und bis heute habe ich das Problem und eine Lösung war immer die Prepaid-Kreditkarte, so dass ich eine Kreditkarte hatte, um online irgendwas kaufen zu können. Und da hatte ich immer diese Kreditkarte, was immer das Erbärmlichste war, wenn du dann irgendwo damit einkaufen wolltest, weil auf der Kreditkarte steht halt nicht dein Name drauf, da steht mein Name bei Name drauf, wo einfach jeder denkt, weil das Konzept Prepaid-Kreditkarte ist, glaube ich nicht so weit verbreitet, dass die Leute checken, dass es ist, sondern da steht einfach mein Name. Herr Name, jetzt hören Sie mir mal zu, Sie können ja wirklich bezahlen. Und einfach so vor allem dann der Blick mein Name auf mich und ich ne, nehmen nicht und denkst einfach ja das ist eine pre-warum nicht ich habe keine ahnung
ich habe dieses fucking finanzsystem nicht verstanden wer kann mir denn erzählen dass wir im
kapitalismus leben ich etwas kaufen will dir geld geben will aber es nicht geht anstatt sagen ja
das ist für dein land nicht erlaubt dein itunes whatever us store geht das nicht du bist
Die will, dir Geld geben will, aber es nicht geht. Anstatt zu sagen, es ist für dein Land nicht erlaubt,
für deinen iTunes, whatever, US-Store geht es nicht. Du bist nicht im richtigen Land.
Das sollte doch meine Freiheit sein, dass man nicht dir Geld geben will.
Wenn wir nicht im Kapitalismus leben, weil man manchmal Leuten, obwohl man den Leuten Geld geben will, es nicht kann.
Wie würdest du dann das System benennen, in dem wir gerade sind?
Ja, Quatsch!
Das ist nichts Halbes und nichts Ganzes.
Das ist einfach ein Haufen nasser Klumpatsch.
In der Phase sind wir gerade. Wir sind im Haufen nasser Klumpatsch
gerade. Ja, das ist einfach alles so
kreuz und quer und alles ein bisschen
davon. Das ist einfach nicht das Richtige
für mich. Kreuz und Ruben.
Irgendwer hat sich versprochen bei dem Ausdruck Kraut und Rüben und hat Kreuth und Ruben gesagt und ich fand das noch besser, weil es noch mehr veranschaulicht, was es gerade ist. Es ist einfach Kreuth und Ruben. Man müsste eigentlich auch sagen, Tobu war Hobu. Ja, irgendwie sowas. Also man müsste das Wort an sich nur durcheinander bringen und Kreuth und Ruben hat das so gut gemacht. Bestimmt irgende irgendein deutsch lk lehrer zeigt jetzt auf und sagt dieses stilmittel hat einen namen um
des chaos zu veranschaulichen worte absichtlich falls zu schreiben falls ihr das stilmittel kennt
schreibt uns so heißt die folge auch kreuth und ruben kreuth und ruben er finde ich schlecht
einfach drunter und ist einfach. Einfach drunter und ...
Es ist einfach drübner und drübner und drunter.
Ja.
Das stimmt schon.
Nee, aber das, ja, ich habe auch das nicht ganz verstanden.
Aber die Wirecard-Kritikkarte war da für dich eine Lösung.
Das ist auch einer der Gründe, warum die nachher raus aufgeflogen sind,
weil eine Journalistin dann irgendwann so ein Werk in den USA besucht hat,
wo ein Mitarbeiter so stolz diese Kritikkarte gezeigt hat. Und dann hat sie gefragt, wie viel kann man denn da draufladen? Und dann meinte er, da gibt es kein Limit. Und dann hat sie so für sich gedacht, Jesus, das ist eine fucking Geldwäsche-Firma, weil natürlich haben es auch andere Banken angeboten, aber die hatten alle ein Limit da drauf, damit dann sowas wie Geldwäsche nicht möglich ist. Und die haben dann kein Limit drauf gehabt und man konnte so 900 Millionen drauf. Malerweise waren 1000 Euro so ein Limit für so eine Prepaid-Grillkarte. Das heißt, du hast in so einer großen Geldwäsche-Firma partizipiert. Ja, ich glaube, ich habe da bestimmt noch irgendwo so 20 Euro drauf rumliegen oder so. Ich bin eigentlich die Leidtragende von diesem ganzen Skandal, dass ich noch Guthaben habe, mit dem ich jetzt nichts mehr machen kann. Ich weiß noch, in ganz frühen Jahren habe ich auch schon irgendwelche besonderen Gutscheinkarten, 10-Euro-Gutscheinkarten an irgendeinem Zigarettenautomaten. Bei uns in der Stadt konnte man eine Gutscheinkarte für 10 Euro kaufen mit einem Code und den habe ich dann, obwohl ich irgendwie 14 war, in einem Online-Casino eingegeben, lange bevor das irgendwie einigermaßen gross war, weil ich von einem Kumpel diesen Roulette-Trick gehört habe, mit dem immer verdoppeln und ich dachte mir, geil, ich habe diesen Trick, ich kann nur reich werden, jetzt muss ich nur irgendwie an Startkapital kommen und habe zehn Euro investiert, habe eine Odyssee vor mir gehabt, einfach um das Geld irgendwie ins Internet zu bringen und er hat natürlich alles verloren, aber ja, ich hätte nämlich diesen Trick auch zum ersten Mal angewandt, als ich zum ersten Mal im Casino war, in Berlin. Schön, Sovi-Kurs ist nach Berlin, da, ja offensichtlich nicht der Mathe-Kurs, nee, das ist ein Sovi und da dachte ich, jetzt ist alles möglich, Kapitalismus, easy, durchgespielt, wir gehen Spieltheorie, wir gehen ins Casino. Ich habe diesen Trick gelernt, kommt alle mit, hat aber nur zehn Euro. Und der Trick funktioniert ja? Glaube nicht so richtig. Die Idee ist, du setzt immer auf rot oder schwarz, also 50-50 Chance, und wenn du verlierst, verdoppelst du deinen Einsatz, sodass wenn du dann gewinnen würdest, insgesamt wieder im Plus bist und hat halt zwei Probleme.
Erstens ist es nicht genau 50-50, weil es gibt null und doppel null und irgendwann geht dir das Geld aus, weil es halt immer verdoppelt, verdoppelt, verdoppelt und irgendwann hast du ja kein Geld mehr, dann ist alles weg. Genau, ich glaube, es funktioniert schon ganz gut, wenn du sagen wir mal 100 Euro hast und du setzt immer einen Euro. Ja, wenn sage mal angenommen, du hast 200 Euro und du willst dir für zwei Euro
eine Sprite kaufen und du sagst,
das will ich jetzt mir kurz erspielen am
Roulett-Tisch, dann glaube ich, geht das mit
relativ guter Sicherheit. Aber es ist halt
immer auch eine kleine Chance, dass du alles verlierst
und dann gehst du durstig nach Hause. Aber die Chance ist sehr gering.
Vergleichsweise gering, aber dafür,
dass du auch nur wenig gewinnen kannst.
Ja, genau. Macht halt keinen Sinn,
wir wollen auch nicht ins Casino treiben. Ich hatte jedenfalls nur zehn Euro und war mir halt todsicher, dass das funktioniert. Und primär hat es das so Gefühl, dass ich, alle manchmal genervt waren, also rotulettisch von mir, weil alle da immer mit so grossen hundert Euro Chips unterwegs waren und ich immer einen Euro auf Rot gesetzt. Und es ist ja, es kostet leicht Energie, mit diesem besenartigen Ding auch noch meinen Chip da zu erreichen. Und deswegen waren, glaube ich, alle ein bisschen genäher. Ja, die machen ja Verlust eigentlich. Das Casino macht Verlust, weil das kostet mehr als ein Euro Energie, den Besen zu bewegen, als die ein Euro, die sie sich einnehmen. Und ich nehme einen Platz ein an diesem Tisch, wo jemand vielleicht einen 32.000-Euro-Chip gelegt hätte. Also eigentlich ist es eine gute Möglichkeit, Casinos in den Ruin zu treiben, also von daher doch gar nicht so schlecht. Ja, okay, gut, einmal full circle gegangen. Aber dass da nicht einer am Tisch auch mal sagt, Junge, das klappt nicht. Ich sehe, was du machst, das funktioniert nicht, kauf dir lieber einen Joghurt. Ich erinnere mich noch an meinen Blick, dass ich jedenfalls zu dem diesem Kugelreinwerfer immer geguckt habe mit diesem Ich weiß, was hier abgeht. Und ich werde nicht besiegen. Ich habe mit so einem Danny Ocean Grinsen quasi durch dieses Casino gelaufen und der Mensch war nicht beeindruckt, das weiß ich noch genau. Na, überraschend, wenn da der 14-jährige pubertierende Stefan einkommt. Nee, wie gerade 18. Wo wahrscheinlich jeder den so anguckt mit so einem, ich hab's verstanden. I know, ich weiß, wie jetzt die läuft. Ich nehme euch jetzt hier aus wie ein Trudan. Pass auf, es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten, weil ich weiß, wie sie läuft. Entweder, da büsst du sofort das ganze Geld, oder ich nehme hier und dann habe ich meinen Zehner hochgehalten, oder ich lasse mein Geld spielen, wende meinen Trick an und wir machen es auf die schmerzhafte Tour. Wir können das jetzt auf die harte Tour oder auf die leichte Tour machen. Geben wir sofort dein Geld oder wir laufen. Herr Müller. Ja, naja, es funktioniert nicht. Es funktioniert nicht. Es funktioniert nicht. Es gibt eine Reihe von Erklärungen. Es gibt auch das Gerücht oder die Verschwörungstheorie. Dabei im Internet findet man manchmal Tipps, wie man im Casino leicht reich werden kann, findet man genau diesen Tipp, dass die von Casinos gestreut werden, diese Videos. Damit Leute absichtlich mit diesem nicht funktionierenden Trick in Casinos rennen und da ihre gut verdienten 10 Euro liegen lassen, anstatt sich davon einfach was Schönes zu kaufen. Jetzt wird es perfide. Blumentopf oder sowas. Eine schöne Blume. Aber anscheinend habe ich mal gehört, das Gerücht. Aber vielleicht stimmt es auch nicht. Jetzt wird es perfide. Aber ich glaube, es ist immer ein coolerer Twist, wenn du sagst, das Gerücht, was du da gerade gehört hast über den und den, wurde von dem und den. Ja. Weil dann macht es immer noch was Größerem. Ja, es ist schon toll, Mensch. Es ist schon toll. Ich kann ja auch Verschwörungstheoretiker verstehen, es ist ja schon spannend, die suchen dann Hinweise und Zeichen und da es gab mal die Mudflat und irgendwie der eigentlich der Grand Canyon ist aus Holz und ja, guckt mal, da sieht man es hier auf diesem Grisselfoto und so. Das ist schon ein cooles, cooler, das ist schon cool. Ich möchte euch dann auf den Weg... Wir alle mal Fakten, du mit deinem Periodensystem, immer, nein, ja, Neon ist eigentlich, Atomgewicht, 4,3, und dann denkst du, ja, wo ist die Fantasie hin, wo ist der Spektakel, wo ist die Spannung in deinem Leben noch, Stefan?
Wo es gerade darum geht, um Verschwörungstheorien, möchte ich euch gerne einen Podcast empfehlen, den ich sehr geliebt habe, mit dem ich durch bin, schon seit ein paar Wochen, der mir nicht aus dem Kopf geht, weil das einfach eine tolle Geschichte ist, ohne zu viel zu verraten. Aber es geht, der Podcast heißt Wind of Change und ist von einem New Yorker Journalisten, des Magazins New Yorker. Und zwar ist der mit einem CIA-Agenten befreundet, der ihm vor einiger Zeit mal die Geschichte erzählt hat, so vor zehn Jahren mal irgendwann so einem besoffenen Abend, dass der Song Wind of Change von The Scorpions, dass man das weiss in der CIA, hat ihm mal irgendwann ein Vorgesetzter erzählt, dass der Song von der CIA geschrieben wurde, um die Sowjetunion zum Fall zu bringen. Und als Deutscher auch gerade, hilarious, lustig, einfach, weil man kennt. Ja, du hast David Hasselhoff im Kopf, der ausgezogen ist, um die Belin der Mauer zu stimmen und es mit einem Lied geschafft hat, also Musik kann sowas bewirken. Ja, genau, und Wind of Change kennt man natürlich als diesen cheesy Pop-Song, der ja ist, und plötzlich kriegt er so eine Bedeutung, jeder kennt ja die Scorpions mit ihren Lederjacken und diesem Rockstar auftreten und so. Und dann fängt der Podcast aber an, so kann ich
vielleicht schon mal verraten, dass sie dann
ja so nach Jahren,
wo die immer wieder drauf kommen,
wenn sie mal abends was trinken gehen und so,
sagen, wir müssen ja mal recherchieren und so.
Und der eine ist halt CIA-Agent, der andere ist Journalist
und dann kommen die halt an den Punkt, wo sie
sagen, okay, komm, wir rufen jetzt einfach mal Leute bei der CIA an.
Ich kenne dann noch ein paar,
sie rufen da an und
erst mal spannender Smalltalk und so, das läuft auch die ganze Zeit
Vielen Dank. Dann kommen die halt an den Punkt, wo sie sagen, okay, komm, wir rufen jetzt einfach mal Leute bei der CIA an. Ich kenne da noch ein paar, sie rufen da an und erst mal spannender Smalltalk und so, es läuft auch die ganze Zeit das Handy mit und recordet. Und in dem Moment, wo das Gespräch auf Wind of Change geht, wird der Mensch, der Agent an dem anderen Ende der Leitung super ernst und sagt, nee, ich kann darüber nicht reden, ich komme in den Knast, nee, wir müssen jetzt aufhören, ciao. Und das ist der Moment, wo man als Zuschauer denkt, what the actual fuck is happening?
Und ja, dann geht es in dem Podcast ganz viel natürlich um die Scorpions, aber es geht auch vor allem um, wie Geheimdienste funktionieren und Geheimagenten damals im Kalten Krieg funktioniert haben. Superspannend, kann ich nur empfehlen, ich wollte die Rechte daran haben für einen Film oder für eine Serie in Deutschland, habe dann Kontakt gehabt mit den Journalisten, der gesagt hat, nee, leider sind die Rechte schon bei Hulu. Ah, verdammt noch. Fand ich aber lustig, hat mich da gefreut. Jedenfalls unbedingt mal reinschauen, vielleicht gibt es dann irgendwann mal eine Serie oder einen Film. Das muss aber super frustrierend sein für so einen Agenten, dass wenn du so einen genialen Plan schmiedest und es schaffst, die Sowjetunion zu Fall zu bringen mit deinem Song, du es niemandem sagen darfst. Ich finde, da müsste es so nach zehn Jahren oder so, müsste es vielleicht die Pflicht geben, dass sie das veröffentlichen. Allein einfach, um coole Storys zu haben. Das ist ja cool, so ein Land, so ein Nationalgefühl lebt ja auch von, wir haben die coolsten Agenten. Einfach mal zu sagen, so, neuer Präsident ist da, und jetzt sag du mal kurz, und dann kommt so ein, der ja gerne sagt, ja, ich habe Snoopy erfunden, um Nordkorea zu infiltrieren. Hat nicht geklappt, macht's gut. Aber lustigerweise war unser Lieblingsfilm Argo sehr häufig eine Runde gespielt, weil die gesagt haben, Argo war zum Beispiel so ein Fall, jetzt haut mal etwas raus, so nach dem Motto, also das ist viel so viel an, jetzt lass uns mal was raushauen, damit auch mal wieder Ruhe ist. Ach so, das tut er nicht an im Prinzip. Es war ja eine CIA-approved story, Argo. Das ist jetzt natürlich die Frage, gibt es nicht jetzt noch eine Next Level Verschwörung, dass die CIA sich diese ganzen Geschichten ausdenkt, damit alle denken, die CIA hätte super krasse Dinge am Laufen, auf die man nie kommt, um die anderen Länder zu verwirren und überall jetzt plötzlich die CIA zu sehen, bei jedem Song, bei jedem neuen Promi, bei jedem Hit. Dabei macht die CIA gar nichts, außer sich den ganzen Tag zu überlegen, stell dir mal vor, wir würden behaupten, wir hätten Wind of Change geschrieben, oder? Nee, ohne Scheiß, lass uns das einfach so tun. Weil immer, wenn wir darüber reden, einfach plötzlich super still werden und sagen, kann man leider nicht so zu sagen. Irgendwann etabliert sich das als Gerücht. Und das Tolle war, dann geht es auch eine Folge darum, jetzt sehe ich doch ein bisschen zu viel, aber es ist ein langer Podcast. Du wärst kein guter CIA-Ger, Stefan. Du bist so, jetzt sag ich's dann noch. Also auf jeden Fall, als ich dann in Moskau war.
Es geht viel darum, ab wann Agenten sagen dürfen, dass sie Agenten sind, ab wann Agenten quasi auch mal ihre Mittel und Wege halt sagen dürfen.
Und dann hat eine Agentin gesagt, ja zum Beispiel darf man von Praktiken oder Methoden erzählen, wenn die Praktiken, dann gibt es dann irgendwann so eine Rundmail und dann heißt es, okay, ab jetzt dürft ihr da und da und darüber erzählen. Die sind nicht mehr klassifiziert, diese Informationen. Und das passiert meistens, wenn es eine bessere Technologie gibt, natürlich. Und dann gab es danach in der Folge irgendwann mal den Punkt, wo die eine Maskenbildnerin interviewt haben, wo es darum ging, um Verschweigerung und Masken und so. Und sie sagt, dass diese Mission Impossible-Masken, diese Truppe in dem Film Mission Impossible, wo man irgendwann Tom Cruise die Maske hat, die dann ist ein ganz anderer, diese Masken kamen tatsächlich mal irgendwann zum Einsatz. Ah, geil. Lustigerweise nach Mission Impossible, nach dem ersten, hat dann die Serie gesagt, so was wäre eigentlich ganz geil, haben daran rumgeforscht, haben auch so Hollywood-Maskenbildner eingestellt und so, also Stichwort nicht nur Popkultur beeinflusst die Politik, sondern auch Politik beeinflusst Popkultur und so weiter, und dann haben die irgendwann das gehabt, und dann hat der Journalist gefragt, warum dürfen sie uns jetzt von diesen Masken erzählen, die es gab, und dann hat sie gesagt, das hat mich auch gefragt. Was natürlich total geil ist, weil es jetzt wahrscheinlich eine bessere Methode gibt, um das Gesicht zu verändern und eine andere Identität zu sein. Was natürlich auch so durch Augmented Reality und so und diese ganzen Technologien, wie du auch mit Videos verarbeiten kannst. Hologramm-Technologie, Deeplight. Du hast dann so einen Chip auf dem Kopf und du hast so ein Hologramm im Gesicht. Ist ja alles machbar. Ja, klar. Ist ja alles machbar mit der heutigen Technologie. Ich nehme an, Deepfake oder so. Also du kannst ja online einfach wie ein ganz anderer Mensch aussehen, wahrscheinlich sehr, sehr akkurat. Aber das fand ich so einen geilen Moment, wo man halt quasi mit dem Wissen, was man vorher hatte, so warum dürfen sie das jetzt verraten? Das ist eine gute Frage, das habe ich auch gefragt. Ja, schon cool. Ich weiß noch, dass irgendein Schulkollege von mir, den ich nicht gut kannte, aber ein Freund von mir war, nicht der hellste, aber irgendwann gesagt hat, übrigens Leute, nur dass ihr es wisst, ich will es euch sagen, ich werde mich beim BND bewerben und ich will nur, dass ihr wisst, dass ich ab dann nicht mehr erzählen kann, was ich so mache. Also das,
ich darf das halt nicht mehr erzählen.
Oder haben alle gesagt, du wirst mit Sicherheit
nicht mehr mit dir in die Gehen.
Und immer ab jetzt,
immer wenn ich den irgendwo sehe oder
über den gesprochen wird, denke ich mir so,
und immer wenn ich ihn sehe, denke ich mir so,
Zwinker, Zwinker, na,
was machst du beruflich?
Was machst du denn gerade? Und er meinte, ja, nee, ich habe jetzt hier so Online-Shop aufgebaut und so und alles so. Okay, viel Erfolg mit deinem Online-Shop. Und der immer so, Alter, hör auf. Was man aber bei Wind of Change auch lernt bei dem Podcast ist, dass je langweiliger der Job ist deines Gegenübers, desto wahrscheinlicher ist es auch, dass er eine Geheimagent ist. Ah, verstehe. Weil die müssen sich ja wirklich an irgendeinem Punkt eine Frage stellen, was sagen die. Ja, deswegen, es gibt ja auch das Gerücht, dass irgendwie Bruce Lee gar nicht gestorben ist, sondern im Untergrund als Geheimagent weitergearbeitet hat. Wo man sich auch die Frage stellt, wenn ihr ein Geheimagent sucht, ist dann wirklich einer der berühmtesten Fernsehstars der Welt die richtige Wahl. Oder gerade deswegen die beste Wahl. Oder genau deswegen, weil man sagt, der kann kein Geheimagent sein, das ist fucking Bruce Lee. Und dann kommt da halt eine Kontaktperson und es ist Bruce Lee und dann denkst du dir, also ist es entweder der beste Agent oder der schlechteste. Also das, keine Ahnung, aber ich glaube auch da kann man sich sagen, nee, ich bin nicht Agent, ich bin ja Bruce Lee, ich bin ja Hollywoodstar. Ich habe auch einen umpeiken Kumpel, der beim BND jetzt in der letzten Runde war, genommen zu werden. Und das war eine Runde, wo dann sehr viele Leute aus seinem Umfeld, manche von denen konnte er bestimmen, manche nicht, interviewt wurden zu ihm. Und dann kam wirklich eine BND-Agentin in einem, wie ich gehört habe, sehr klischeehaften Agenten-Outfit an und hat wirklich so zwei Stunden von der Decke runtergeseilt. Wurde runtergeseilt und dann unten Laser, die gar keine Rolle gespielt haben, aber sie ist dann so wirklich davor gelandet und hat dann so mit so einem Headset, so einem Bluetooth-Headset gesagt, Mission accomplished. Und sie hat mich dann zwei Stunden Zeit genommen, mit jedem zu sprechen, und zwar ein Kind, Kinderfreund quasi, mit dem man jetzt keinen Kontakt mehr hat. Eltern. Und den hat sie selber gefunden oder er musste die Kontakte geben? Er hat die Kontakte gegeben, aber ich glaube, sie hat ihn auch schon selber gefunden. Ja, ja, okay. Und die Fragen waren wohl, also alle haben sich gefühlt, als wären sie gerade in so einem fucking Kreuzverhör und wären illegal und alle hatten wahnsinnige Angst, mit ihr zu sprechen und so. Und es war sehr interessant, er wurde am Ende nicht genommen und dann ist natürlich auch so ein bisschen die Frage, ja, wer hat jetzt vor euch verkackt? Ach, das ist ja krass. Weil an irgendeinem Punkt ... Moment, aber da wird gefragt, ob der das geheim genug gehalten hat, beim BND zu sein, oder ob der einfach Dreck am Stecken hat. Das ist wie unser guter Arbeits-Sketch mittlerweile gerade auch. Kennst du unseren guter Arbeits-Sketch, den zweiten guter Arbeits-Sketch über den BND? Ja, den zweiten? Das war unser zweiter Sketch, meine ich, nach Brunch. Moment, der aber nie veröffentlicht wurde.
Der wurde veröffentlicht, der BND-Sketch wurde veröffentlicht.
Ja, aber wie du meinst jetzt, ach so der zweite
in der Chronologie. Der zweite Sketch,
ich dachte, es gibt noch einen zweiten BND-Sketch.
Ach so, nee, nee, nee.
Es ging nicht darum, ob man ein guter
Agent ist, es ging nur darum, um
politische Gesinnung, Drogen,
Verlässlichkeit,
Loyalität und sowas. Ach krass. Ja, also sehr interessant. Und ich dachte auch, was sind Zeitverschwendungen? Also cool, auch auf eine Art kommen da am Ende wahrscheinlich Leute dann in die letzte Runde, die wirklich dann keine Nazis sind, die keine Idioten sind, die am Kopf gefallen sind. Aber was auch eine Riesenverschwendung an Geld und Ressourcen und Zeit quasi bei jedem Menschen, der sich da bewirbt, dann irgendwie so, die sind auch gereist, diese Frau ist dann halt durch ganz Deutschland gereist, um halt diese Freunde aus verschiedenen Lebensabschnitten zu interviewen. Krass, ja, fand ich krass. Wow. Da habe ich wahrscheinlich alles nicht erzählt, aber scheiße. Aber auch die, die die vorstellen, du kriegst deinen Traumjob nicht, weil deine Freunde voll Idioten sind.
Und er auch denkt so, wow, du hast alles richtig gemacht, hart gelernt, studiert alles und dann einfach, nee, weil Paul hat erzählt, ihr wart da irgendwie als Kind, habt ihr da so einen Kaugummiautomaten aufgebrochen? Habt ihr Wahlplakate überklebt? Und du so, dieser alte Scheiße. Es kann bitte nicht, das vielleicht nicht weitererzählen. Schon krass. Aber finde ich eine interessante Idee, aber auch hier vielleicht, ich vermute da immer noch eine zweite Ebene, dass das gar nicht stimmt, sondern dass die nur wollen, dass man denkt, dass BND-Agenten so krass sind. Die machen es halt mal. Die machen es halt mal und alle denken das und erzählen es dann in ihrem Podcast, weil das ist ja kein Zufall, dass sie genau mit jemandem gesprochen haben, der einen Freund hat, der einen Podcast hat. Du meinst, ich bin ein Ziel geworden und bin reingefallen.
Du bist das eigentliche Ziel. Über dich soll gestreut werden, dass der BND super kompetent ist und irgendwie die ganzen russischen Agenten, die gerade mithören, denken, oh fuck, vielleicht haben wir einen Maulwurf im Haus. Aber es passt alles, also auch was dein Studiengang und so, Politik. Ich habe auch einen Kumpel, der zum BND gehen wollte.
So, sind wir komplett Marionetten? Alles, also auch was, dein Studiengang und so, Politik. Ich habe auch einen Kumpel, der zum BND gehen wollte.
So.
Sind wir komplett Marionetten?
Sind Podcaster-Marionetten, sind wir nicht einfach alles staatlich gelenkte Mittel, um hier in der ...
Ich meine, wenn es die fucking Scorpions erwischt, warum sollten wir verschont bleiben?
Wir hängen da genauso mit drin.
So, jetzt für euch Zuschauer Mindfuck,
wie wäre es, wenn wir einfach BND-Agenten sind?
Und aber mit welchem, was ist unser Ziel?
Ja, wir, Woche für Woche, bestimmen wir doch quasi Inhalte.
Wir sagen, worum es geht.
Wir lenken euch ab von den eigentlichen Dingen,
die gerade über euren Köpfen passieren.
Ja, ja, ja, hin zur Pfauen-Hotline.
Damit ihr da anruft und eure Geheimnisse den Pfauen ...
Äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, nein, ruft da gerne an.
Und die Pfauern fragen dann natürlich nicht,
aha, und planen sie mal irgendwie Auslandsreise,
Kontakt zu Agenten, fremder Geheimdienste oder so?
Und wenn die Pfauen verschiedene Freunde aus eurer Lebenssituation haben wollen,
dann sagt einfach mal, gibt denen die mal, weil es sind Pfauern.
Nein, die müssen es abchecken, die müssen es halt einfach abchecken, weil die wollen halt auch sicher gehen, dass ihre Arbeitsplätze sicher sind. Um einmal im Ernst, es sind scheiß Pfau. Eben. Wolltet ihr denen diese Information verwehren? Es sind Pfau. Natürlich, guckt ihr die an. Pfauen? Ja, Pfau. Die kann man super leicht wiedererkennen. Du wirst nie den Pfau aus den Augen verlieren, weil der einen riesigen bunten Federnstrauß hat. Ist jeder Federstrauß eines Pfauen gleich oder ist es wie Fingerabdrücke? Nee, ich glaube, das ist wie ein Schmetterling. Du hast da schon unterschiedliche Motive, also du hast da so ein Leopardenmuster, du hast so ein Streifenmuster, zickzack, irgendwie dieses 90er-Jahre-Muster, du hast da alles drauf. Gibt es da auch Modetrends? Also wenn man jetzt wirklich die Pfauensträusse anschaut über die letzten hundert Jahre, zu sagen, jetzt knallige Farben oder irgendwie so pastellige Formen und dann so alle Pfauen. In den 70ern war es ja so ein bisschen gedeckt. So, da waren es Wes Anderson Farben. Das ist gar kein dummes Meme-Bild eigentlich, oder? So die unterschiedlichen Moden im Laufe der Zeit und dann so 50er, 30er und dann halt die Zaunen dabei. Und jetzt tragen die wieder Converse.
Ja.
Haut's raus!
Das ist unser Meme, die Meme-Lords.
Ich hätte neulich gedacht, jetzt kommen die Converse schon wieder zurück. Also ich bin ja ein bisschen...
Waren sie hier weg? Ich bin denn
Mode-Sprach-Fernglas-
Sprachrohr,
weil du kriegst ja nichts mit von der
Mode-Welt. Deswegen habe ich das Gefühl, manchmal muss ich dir was mitgeben. Die Converse kommen zurück. Okay. Und die waren halt... Müssen wir uns verteidigen? Nee, und jetzt denke ich mir, ich werde alt, weil die waren schon mal weg. Dann kamen sie irgendwann, als ich so 13 war, kam Converse. Ja, aber werden die Zykel nicht immer schneller, Stefan? Jetzt kommen die wieder. Sind die Retrozykel nicht immer schneller geworden? Übrigens hier ganz kurz Entschuldigung in eigener Sache, auch von Stefan. Weiß ich noch nicht, ob ich das so... Wir haben vor ein paar Folgen, haben wir locker 20 Minuten lang über das Thema gesprochen, was wäre, wenn Motten Modedesigner wären. Ja. Also wenn man die einfach mal machen lassen würde an der Kleidung. Was, wenn man Motten mal machen lässt und mal guckt, was die wollen. Genau, und wir haben überlegt, wie wäre es denn, wenn wir eine eigene Kleidungsreihe machen, die von Motten designt würde. Und wir sind nicht auf den Gag Klamotten gekommen. Oh mein Gott. Und da möchte ich sagen, da habt ihr Besseres verdient. Sorry. Das tut uns richtig leid. Manchmal fällt es einem nicht ein, aber das war unerhört. Das tut uns wirklich, wirklich leid. Wir möchten den Gag hier nachreichen. Zum Beispiel in der Form. Diese Modefirma, die könnte ja Klamotten heißen, oder? Ja, also sowas. Damit haben wir unsere Pflicht erfüllt. Es tut uns sehr, sehr leid. Wir gehen da in uns und versprechen, dass das so nicht funktioniert. Hugomoth. Hugomoth, wunderbar. Kann man jetzt alles natürlich leicht sagen, klar. Aber die Zeit ist vorbei. Also das war das Podcast UFO-Gag-Nachreichung.
Auch ich möchte mich. Nee, nee, das war es nicht.
Nee, okay, alles klar, wir lassen die
Rubrik offen, weiter geht's.
Weitere Entschuldigung. Ja, weil ich habe mich nämlich
ähm, ich habe erzählt
von meinen Schweizer Freunden, die mir diese
Geschichte erzählt haben von dem Teufel.
Korrekt. Der die Brücke gebaut hat,
die Teufelsbrücke in der Schweiz. Die erste Seele, die die Brücke
überquert, sollte dem Teufel geweiht sein, aber ein Huhn wurde vorangetrieben. Ich habe gesagt, das ist so eine Schweizer Gründungsgeschichte, bla bla bla, ist dick dicht verankert da irgendwie in der Vergangenheit der Schweizer. Alle Schweizer wissen das, sind stolz darauf. Turns out, jede Stadt Deutschlands, vielen Dank für alle Nachrichten, hat eine Geschichte mit dem Teufel. Nein, und der Steinbrücke. Nee, nicht immer den Brücken. Aber die Regensburger Brücke, das ist quasi genau die gleiche Story. Auch mit einem Huhn oder Hahn war es da, meine ich. Und der wurde auch verarscht und war dann ganz sauer. Und dann gibt es das mit dem Regensburger Brücke, ich glaube, der Aachener, vielmehr einfach eure Nachrichten, alles identische Geschichten, ich habe sehr viele Nachrichten bekommen,
und dann kam auch eine Geschichte, mir kam eine Geschichte bekannt vor,
und zwar von der Rialto-Brücke in Venedig.
Ja.
Und zwar, da kam dann ein Bild vom lieben, weiß ich nicht, wie du heisst, mit Vornamen,
weil dein Instagram-Name keinen Hinweis aufgibt, die Legende vom Teufel auf der Rialto-Brücke. Als im 16. Jahrhundert die Rialto-Brücke gebaut wurde, hatte laut Legende der Teufel seine Hände im Spiel und verlangte die Seele des ersten Nebelwesens, das die Brücke überqueren würde. Anderenfalls würde die Brücke nie fertig werden. So, der Architekt da Ponte akzeptierte die Forderung und gedachte einen Hahn, wieder Hahn, als Ersten über die Brücke stolzieren zu lassen. Aber jetzt? Und ich glaube langsam, nee, das stimmt alles und der Teufel hat es jetzt gelernt. Der Teufel, der die List des Architekten durchschaut hatte, ging deshalb zu ihm nach Hause, sagte seiner Frau, man würde sie auf der Brücke erwarten. Diese war schwanger, ging aber sofort zur Brücke, die Seele des totgeborenen Kindes soll noch lange auf der Brücke herumgeirrt sein. Also er hat sein eigenes Kind dann dem Teufel geopfert? Nein. Der Teufel? Ja, ja, ja. Ja, genau. Aber der... Alter, aber das einzige Mal, dass der Teufel gewinnt. Genau, ist dann in Venedig bei der Rialto-Brücke. Und da ernt jetzt immer noch das rückgeborene Kind herum. Also irgendwie steht der letzte Satz in diesem ... Es fängt an wie ein Märchen und dann wird es schlimm, also ich weiß auch nicht, plötzlich wird es sehr dark, aber also irgendwie interessant, dass der Teufel dann da beschlossen hat.
Aber erst mal interessant zu sehen, dass irgendwie dieser ganze Märchenkulturelle Hinterbau, die deutschen Traditionen einfach eins zu eins geklaut ist einfach, dass sie alle voneinander klauen, alle Städte anscheinend.
Immer so.
Und wahrscheinlich, vielleicht war wirklich eine Brücke damals so unerklärbar, wie es
irgendwie möglich sein soll,
sowas wie eine Brücke zu bauen oder generell
große Bauwerke, dass man halt gesagt hat,
da muss doch der Teufel involviert gewesen sein.
Das ist doch ein Teufelswerk. Ja.
Und dann mit der
schwangeren Frau, das ist ja ich gemeint.
Ich dachte gerade, klar,
die erste Szene, die die Brücke überquert, ist das Kind. Weil sie nicht rückwärts gegangen ist, Das war es auch ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, das Kind tot geboren. Aber die Frau hat überlebt vielleicht. Aber es heißt ja, dass das Kind immer noch herumirrt. Der Architekt der Brücke hieß Da Ponte? Das ist das Detail, worauf du gesagt hast. Heißt Ponte nicht Brücke? Da Ponte. Nee, Ponte heisst Brücke? Was heisst Brücke auf Italienisch? Ponte Deutsch. Brücke. Der Architekt der Brücke hieß Doktor Brücke?
Ja, vor allem, es ist die Rialto-Brücke und der Architekt heißt ausgerechnet Brücke. Wir haben die Brücke doch noch Ihnen benannt, die Rialto-Brücke. Ja, Freunde, aber, ach komm. Wieso, wenn wir die Brücke-Brücke nennen oder was? Wollen wir sie Ponte-Ponte nennen? Aber hat er deswegen den Bauauftrag bekommen oder heißt er Brücke, weil er Brücken bauen konnte? Kann er auch sein, weiß ich nicht. Oder er hat immer schon seine Familie Brücken gebaut, weiß ich nicht. Ich finde gut, dass das das Detail ist, auf dem sie uns stürzen, nachdem eine Todgeburt, das Teufelswerk Ursache ist. Fuck, ey, interessant, aber das müssen wir mal klären. Ey, auch gut zu sehen, dass der Teufel weiterlernt, finde ich gut, dass es sich entwickelt, dass er zweihundertmal im Allgäu und in Süddeutschland über die Nase gezogen wurde, seine Nase wurde über den Tisch gezogen und er in Venedig dann aber gesagt hat, Schluss damit, jetzt hänge ich meine... Nee, an der Nase herumgeführt oder über den Tisch gezogen. Und er dann gesagt hat, nee, jetzt in Venedig gebe ich Vollgas, jetzt geht es weiter. Er wurde mit der Nase hinters Licht gezogen. Genau, ja, seine Nase wurde hinters Licht gezogen. Über den Tisch gezogen, hinters Licht. Aber finde ich gut, auch mehr über den Teufel zu hören. Also falls ihr noch Storys über den Teufel habt, wo ist der gerade, wo hält er sich auf? Viel hat er nicht mehr gemacht in den letzten Jahren. Ich dachte vor allem so, das wäre jetzt ja quasi die Aufgabe der Late-Light-Show. Interview-Gast der Teufel. Der Teufel. Einfach so mit ganz in so einem Weihwasser-Planschbecken oder so einem Donut, wo er in der Mitte so fixiert ist, dass er nicht raus kann, weil überall Weihwasser ist. Und dann wird er interviewt und er sagt dann, der Erste, der mir eine Frage stellt, dessen Seele... Aber nicht so schnell! Der Erste, die Erste Seele, die ihm eine Frage stellt, gehört mir.
Und dann so ein scheiß Pfau mit so einem Bügelmikrofon am Schnabel so auf dem Kopf. Und du, nein! Mein alter Todfeind, das Huhn! Ich habe tausende Hühnerseelen bei mir zu Hause rumliegen. Ich brauche keine einzige weitere. Ich kann das Geschnatter nicht mehr hören. Die sind fast nichts wert auf dem Seelenmarkt. Ach ja, aber nein. Ja, der macht nicht mehr viel. Ich glaube, der hat noch mal einen kurzen Auftritt in Vampire Diaries, die irgendwie nach acht Staffeln einfach keine Bösewichte mehr hatten und einfach gesagt haben, fuck it, der Teufel. Raus, raus, raus. Why not? Weg, raus, raus, stell, raust du, wir brauchen irgendwas. Und er so, oh. Nimm den Teufel, schnell. Und er mit so ganz vielen Hühnern im Arm so, oh, okay. Schnell, schnell, dreizack, dreizack, dreizack, schnell. Und dann einfach, ja, und dann glaube ich, viele hat er nicht mehr gemacht danach. Wie stellst du dir jetzt mal, nicht nachdenken, wie stellst du den Teufel vor? Nicht nachdenken, erklär. Knallrot, erklär. Knallrot, schiefe Zähne und Ziegenbeine. Ziegenbeine auch. Und Reizack auf jeden Fall. Schwanz? Gespalten. Gespalten, Schwanz, Zunge, oder? Und die Zunge? Kurz und breit. Kurze, breite Zunge. Aber nach wem erinnert dich das Gesicht? Das Gesicht des Teufels. Nicht nachdenken. Stell dir vor, das Gesicht des Teufels.
Wie sieht es am ehesten aus?
Wie Hugo, diese weirde Spielfigur Hugo aus diesem Spiel.
Das ist auch so ein Kobold-Typ.
Hast du das Spiel nicht gerne gespielt?
Ungern.
Das hat niemand gerne gespielt.
Doch, ich habe es gerne gespielt.
Na, glaube ich nicht. Nicht so gerne.
Nicht so wie Bugdum. Und das kenne ich gerne. Ich bin nicht gerne gespielt. Doch, ich habe es gerne gespielt. Na, glaube ich nicht. Nicht so gerne. Nicht so wie Bugdum oder andere Spiele. Das kenne ich gerne, ich Bugdum.
Aber ja, obwohl man ja tatsächlich sagen muss,
technisch gesehen ist das gar nicht so ganz korrekt,
weil Teufel ist nur eine Art von Dämon.
Lucifer selbst ist ja der eigentlich, den man als Teufel bezeichnet,
aber Teufel ist nur so eine Art von Dämonen, die halt diese Ziegenbeine haben und so ein Kram. Also eigentlich ist Teufel nur die Überkategorie, aber ob Lucifer auch ein Teufel ist oder ob Teufel nur im Gefolge des Lucifers steht, bin ich mir gar nicht so hundertprozentig sicher. Also da muss man höllisch aufpassen. Da muss man im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes höllisch aufpassen. Damit man da zu Karneval, kommt ja bald, wir freuen uns, keine Fehler macht, dass man dann nicht den Dämon-Teufel ... Kennt man ja, dass man zu seinem Teufelkostüm interviewt wird und die knallharten Fragen kommen. Aber ich frage mich gerade, so Late-Light-Show, die können ja nicht immer Saints zu Gast haben. Oh doch, glaub mir, es gibt eine fucking Menge. Es gibt dann irgendwie den Heiligen der Küche, es gibt den Heiligen der Feuerwehr, Heilige der Autobahn, Heilige des Klettergattens. Ja, aber du musst ja irgendwann mal auch der anderen Seite, der dunklen Seite der Macht quasi die Chance geben. Die AfD muss ja auch gewisse Redeanteile in Talkshows haben, weißt du? Ja. Ich denke mir, der Teufel hat auch ein Recht, sauer zu sein gerade, quasi in der Late-Light-Show ist noch nicht vorgekommen zu sein.
Wenn du jetzt den Teufel persönlich einlädst, hast du halt schon ein False-Balance-Problem oder so, dass du dann schon vielleicht einen von den lameren Heiligen erstmal nimmst.
Irgendwie vor allem, du brauchst ja auch neue Heilige, also es muss ja auch einen Heiligen der Tag-Team, der Laser-Tag-Hallen geben oder sowas.
Dann brauchst du halt neue Leute, die jetzt sterben. Ich meine, wenn du jetzt stirbst, wirst du halt der Heilige von TikTok oder irgendwie sowas. Gott. Und du auch denkst, boah, lame, früher halt Heiliger der Getreide, Heiliger des Weins und so, geil, halt richtig cool. Aber heute ist das halt alles irgendwie dann der Sendemasten oder der Windräder vielleicht sowas. Das könnte vielleicht nur interessant sein. Heilige der Windräder oder so.
Die müssen das dann wieder neu aufteilen.
Wer ist dafür zuständig jetzt mit den Heiligen?
Schwierig, aber heute wirst du ja auch kaum noch
heilig. Zwei Wunder, glaube ich, braucht man
mittlerweile. Zwei vom Vatikan
bestätigte Wunder. Was ist so ein Wunder? Wer macht denn das heute noch?
Was wäre so ein Wunder? Wer hat denn da heute noch Bock drauf?
Ja, und wer erlebt trotzdem noch Wunder?
Ja, das ist das Problem. Du kannst ja im Vorhinein schlecht sagen,
was ein Wunder ist, weil es ist ja per Definition unerwartet. Aber ist dem Mann Wunder passiert? Ich würde sagen, ja, aber jetzt im streng religiösen Sinne. Es ist ein vom Vatikan abgelehntes Wunder. Ich habe es eingereicht beim Vatikan. Es wurde aber abgelehnt. Hat mir so eine Wunder-Hotline? Ich glaube, die haben 0800 Wunder und da kann man einfach anrufen und kam mich nicht mal durch die erste Runde. Also ich kam gar nicht zum Interview meiner Freunde, sondern die haben sofort gesagt, kein Problem. Ich kann das Wunder kurz zusammenfassen. Ich hatte In-Ear-Kopfhörer mit so Gumminöppeln oben drauf. Wie bist du der Heilige der In-Ears? Mit so Gumminöppeln drauf, kennst du ja, die haben dann noch mal so Gumminöppeln. Du hast diese Indie-Kopfhörer und da sind drei Grössen von Gumminöppeln dabei. Und das Wunder ist, dass eins genau passt. Und ich habe natürlich sehr kleine, enge Ohren, also da kommt wirklich fast nichts rein, wahnsinnig eng. Und deswegen habe ich mir auch die kleinsten Gumminöppel natürlich aufgestülpt. Und wie man das aber erkennt, man steckt die manchmal ein, man zieht die wieder raus aus der Jacke, diese Gumminöppel gehen manchmal ab und sind verloren. Und dann habe ich natürlich mein Leid geklagt, nicht zu knapp.
An Gott. Nein, nicht an Gott, nein. Und deswegen müssen Verlore ausgefallen beim Vatikan. Das kann gut sein, ja, vielleicht hätte ich das anders erzählen sollten. Aber ich habe es mein Leid geklagt dem Kumpel Sepp, Sebastian, genannt Sepp, damals noch in der Frank-Elsa-Masterclass-Zeit.
Das sind alles diese ganzen unbichten Details. Brauchst du in der Wunderhautlein?
Ja, der Kardinal im Vatikan war da schon gelangweilt, sichtlich, laut Schnaufen.
Jeder.
Und dann klage ich dem mein Leid, bin mit dem unterwegs in Berlin und sage, ah scheiße, jetzt kann ich immer nur eine Seite hören, bei vielen Beatles-Songs und so hast du ja unterschiedliche Spuren auf Stereo, da hörst du dann nur die Rassel auf einer Seite. So, wann was da runter? Und du denkst dir halt, Alter, ist das jetzt hier irgendwie, ist das hier Yellow Submarine oder Yellow Russell oder was? Und ich denke mir, meine Güte, bei Podcasts geht's, die sind oft Mono abgemischt und so, aber bei vielen Songs einfach die Hölle. Und in dem Moment, in dem ich mit dem das berede, schaue ich vor mich und denke mir, Moment mal, was liegt denn da auf dem Boden? Da liegt doch was Schwarzes vor mir auf dem Boden, was ist denn das ein Käfer? Ja, okay. Ich habe gerade eine Podcast-Idee gehabt, weil ich dachte gerade, okay, es war einfach Sepp, der genervt war von einer Story, einfach weil er die gleichen Kopfhörer haben alle bekommen hat, weil er von der Masterclass Größe nach vorne geworfen, damit er endlich eine Fresse hält mit der langweiligen Geschichte. Und das kam heraus. Podcast-Idee, es gibt keine Wunder. Wie Eterwe und Sepp, ah, okay. Podcast-Idee, es gibt keine Wunder. Sondern Sepp steht hinter jedem Wunder eigentlich. Nee, reicht uns euer Wunder ein, wo er neben ihr sagt, das ist irre, was mir da passiert ist. Und wir die Banken. Und wir recherchieren in knallharter Detailgetreu. Ja. Bis ins letzte Detail, so Serial-mässig oder so richtig investigativer True Crime Podcast, was genau da passiert ist, damit es zu diesem Wunder kam. Miracle Busters. The Miracle Busters. There is no Miracles. Yeah. We're living in hell. There is no hope. Death is the end. This is literal hell. There is no hope. Das ist der Untertitel. Aber ich glaube ja, das ist ja tatsächlich so, du musst ja zwei nachgewiesene Wunder haben vom Vatikan um Heidegger. Das ist ja tatsächlich so. Das heißt, es muss ja... Zwei nachgewiesene Wunder. Das heißt, bei einem Wunder kriegt ja jeder. Das heißt, es muss ja da Leute geben, und das ist jetzt gar nicht lächerlich machend gemeint, es muss ja Leute geben, die prüfen, ob wirklich an einem Ort ein Wunder geschehen ist oder nicht. Braunschlag zum Beispiel ist ja die Geschichte von so einem Ort, der ein Wunder faked, um als Wahlfahrtsort finanziell besser dazustehen. Und die faken halt ein Wunder. Tolle Serie aus Österreich, schöner Humor, Braunschlag, schaut euch gerne an. Und da muss ja dann auch jemand vom Vatikan kommen und sagen, was ist hier passiert? Genau, war das ein Wunder oder wollt ihr mich hier übers Kreuz legen? Und da muss es ja Miracle Busters geben, die vom Vatikan ausziehen, was auch eine geile Sitcom ist, von vielleicht so ein tiefgläubiger Christ, der denkt an die Wunder, aber geht dann immer hin und merkt, das ist reiner Bullshit, der meint da so, ja, ich hatte da irgendwie noch so ein halbes Salamibrot liegen und dann gehe ich kurz weg und dann komme ich zurück und dann ist es weg und mein Hund guckt mich irgendwie komisch an. Da habe ich dann und da denkt sich, Leute, das ist ja scheiße. Pass auf, die Sitcom ist, zwei
Deppen, die, weil
vom Vatikan werden natürlich immer Idioten
abgestellt dafür, zu diesen Städten
zu reisen und diese
Mettbrötchen-Inzidenz zu haben und
erste Folge ist lustig, lustig, lustig, die
reisen überall hin, irgendwo Süddeutschland,
irgendwie Quatsch und so und
am Ende der ersten Folge, die kommen zu einem
Ort, wo wirklich einfach fucking Wunder passiert. Du kannst nicht erklären erklären. Niemand kann es erklären, alle sind amazed abspann. Und dann geht die Staffel los. Wie die halt dann dieses scheiß Wunder. Nee, dann ist es einfach vorbei. Dann ist die ganze Serie vorbei, weil es abgesetzt wurde. Ja. Nein, aber dann sind die wahnsinnig stolz, weil diese beiden Idioten haben dann Wunder. Und plötzlich sind diese zwei Idioten die wichtigsten Menschen in einem katholischen Glaube. Ja, oder sie sind halt selber nur so halbgläubig und machen das nur so als Abhakenjob und finden dann aber ihren Glauben neu, weil sie tatsächlich ein Wunder gefunden haben. Oder man macht es genau andersrum, die sind supergläubig und sehen dann aber, dass sie Wunder gar nicht gibt und sie verlieren dadurch ihren Glauben und finden irgendwas Neues. Alles interessant. Hobby, Federball. Oder halt Podcast, wir die Banken, eure Dreckswunder. Ja, falls ihr wirklich sagt, wir haben Wunder, also wir können ja sagen, wenn wir es gut finden, dann reichen wir es für euch beim Vatikan ein. Und wenn wir sagen, nein, Bullshit, wir versuchen es auf jeden Fall so hart auseinanderzunehmen, dass wenn es unserem Test besteht, auch der Vatikan da nichts mehr zu sagen kann. Ich würde sagen, wir sind bereit, mit quasi der ganzen geballten Podcast-Ufo-Macht eure Wunder einzureichen beim Vatikan. Aber dafür müssen wir das Wunder wirklich genauestens untersuchen. Wir reichen da keinen Scheiß ein. Wir wollen die nicht behelligen. Die haben genug anderen Scheiß zu tun. Kinder anfassen und sowas. Die haben halt, weißt du, da ist halt Schedule. Wir haben. Ich habe jetzt gerade zehn Minuten Maximum, ich glaube, jetzt gerade zehn Minuten maximal Zeit. Acht Messina noch heute, what the fuck. So, und deswegen müssen wir quasi, ne, irgendwie gucken, stimmt das, was du uns da erzählt? Und Leute, ihr kennt uns doch, wir werden jetzt nicht einfach eure Wunder als unsere verkaufen, damit wir die Heiligen des Podcasts werden. Nein. Nein. Das ist doch Quatsch, das würden wir doch nicht machen. Vielleicht würden wir uns räumern. Ihr kennt uns doch gut genug, wir nehmen euch doch nicht auf den Tisch. Nein, großes Sternchen trotzdem an dieser Stelle, für später. Ja, aber kurzes Audisignal signalisiert Ironie jetzt gleich. Aber nein, würden wir natürlich niemals machen. Nein. Und das wäre ebenfalls spannend für die nächste Folge. Reicht uns eure Wunder ein. Und dann sehe ich da vor mir so was Schwarzes liegen und denke mir, ja, was kann das sein? Jeder weiß es. Hebe ich es auf und ihr glaubt nicht, was das war. Das kleine schwarze Ding war genau so ein Gummiaufsatznöppel in genau der Grösse. In klein, in genau der Grösse. Es war nicht meines, sondern es war ein anderes, das ich da gefunden habe. Habe ich abgewaschen und benutzt. Ist dir noch ein anderes in ihr? Muss es denn ... Wir spulen ein paar Monate vor. Bitte nicht, ey. Und ich bin hier auf dem Weg, tatsächlich hier auf dem Hof vom Studio, bin ich auf dem Weg mit einem Kollegen, gehe ich hin und dem erzähle ich diese Story. Bob. Wir nennen Bob. Und ich erzähle Bob diese Story und sage, das war Wahnsinn, ne, also da habe ich genau diesen Gummipinöpel gebraucht. Und dann habe ich genau, als ich jemandem davon erzählt habe, wieder eingesehen, von dem Problem, habe ich Sepp ja gerade in dem Moment erzählt, mir ist dieser Gummipinöpel vor. Ja, du hast den geschaut. Und dann finde ich den Gummipinöpel. Und in dem Moment, in dem ich Bob das erzähle, sechs Monate früher, später, es hilft auch nicht, dass du dich an den Orkeit sprichst. Schaue ich vor mir auf die Strasse und denke mir, Moment mal, was liegt denn da? Sepp. Was liegt denn da? Das ist ja mal ein fucking Twist. Sepp, tot und überfahren. Und dann kommt Sepp in die Obduktion und ich frage mich, woran ist er gestorben, stellt sich raus, er hatte so einen schwarzen Gumminöppel genau in der Aorta stecken und deswegen ist er gestorben. Wahnsinn, ne? Also was da passiert, leider zu dem Zeitpunkt, der Vatikan-Korrespondent völlig gelangweilt hat, aufgelegt und ja, reicht nicht. Also das, es muss schon krasser sein als das. Wir müssen es noch Italienisch einreichen. Oder Latein. Ich glaube Latein. Oh, oh, oh, da müssen wir übersetzen. Nee, das ist kein Problem. Bitte kein Genitiv benutzen in eurer Beschreibung. Nee, bitte kein Genitiv, aber das kriegen wir schon hin. Nur Akkusativ und den normalen. Ich hab Latino, wir kriegen das, ich hab Latino. Ja, ich hab halt keinen. Wir kriegen das schon hin. Aber es muss krasser sein als die Gummi-In-Ihr-Kopfhörer-Geschichte. Das ist das Mindestmaß. Ich bin jetzt kurz davor zu glauben, du bist vielleicht der Heilige in ihr Nöppel-Nübel. Weil du hast es immerhin schon zweimal bekommen, dieses Wunder. Ja, kann sein. Und ich hab mir tatsächlich gedacht, an dem Tag, was mache ich jetzt? Soll ich jetzt Lotto spielen?
Am zweiten Tag hast du es gedacht. Weil wenn man merkt, okay, ich habe Glück, dann ist es ja dumm, das nicht auszunutzen. Soll ich an dem Tag Lotto spielen? Weil stell dir mal vor, jetzt eine Idee für eine Kurzgeschichte, jemand hat immer Glück und hat immer Glück irgendwie irgendwas, vielleicht etwas Traumatisches, irgendwie Autounfall, Schulbus, Schulbus fällt die Klippe runter, alle 40 Kinder tot ein Überlebender. So, nächster Tag Flugzeug abstürzt, nur er überlebt und dann findet er den Gumminöppel und denkt sich, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Stimmt, beim Gumminöppel, da ist dann vorbei. Das kann es ja nicht sein. Und dann denkt er sich, also jetzt muss ich es mal auf die Spitze treiben. Geht zum Lottoladen, sagt, ein Lottoschein bitte, die Zahlen, keine Ahnung, schaut sich so im Raum um und sieht verschiedene Zahlen oder sowas. Drei, fünf, oder er benutzt Zahlen aus seiner Lebensgeschchieden. Geil, gute Idee. Aus seiner Lebensgeschieden. Das Ticket. Genau, Ticket und vielleicht irgendwie dann so das Datum von dem Busunfall oder sowas in der Richtung als Lottozahlen. Und er gibt das an, so drei, fünf, acht, sechsundzwanzig, vierundzwanzig, zack, Hauptgewinn, zack, 16 Millionen Euro geworden mit dem ersten Ticket. Und dann ist die Frage, ab welchem Punkt kippt das Ganze, wo er sich denkt, also das muss doch einen Preis haben. Ich kann doch nicht einfach so glücklich sein. Und in dem Moment kommt der Teufel und sagt, aber nicht so schnell, denn das erste Kind, was du gebärst, beziehungsweise nicht du, sondern deine Frau, gehört mir.
Und dann versucht er dem Teufel ein Schnippchen zu schlagen und versucht einen Huhn zu befruchten. Da wird die Kurzgeschichte ein bisschen weird und sehr detailreich. Sehr detailliert. Also alle Sinne werden unerträglich detailliert geschrieben. Was viele nicht wissen, das war das Vorwort zur Doktorarbeit im Genmanipulation, wie der Versuch, wie eine Frau theoretisch einen Huhn gebären könnte. Das war das Vorwort. Und er schafft es dann tatsächlich, weil er so viel Glück hat, mit dem Huhn ein Kind zu zeugen. Und das kommt auf die Welt. Aber er dachte, das wird irgendein Monster oder irgendwas, was entbehrlich wäre. Aber er verliebt sich in das Kind. Er sieht sich selbst. In sein Kind. Er sieht sich. Er verliebt sich in sein Kind. Naja, also so eine Eltern. Und der Teufel sagt, ich will damit nichts zu tun haben. Nein, ich meine nicht im romantischen Sinne halt so eine Elternliebe, wo man halt sagt, okay, er liebt dieses Kind. Ja, dann seid nicht verliebt. Ja gut, er liebt dieses Kind und denkt, ja, das bin ich. Ich will dieses Kind grossziehen. Aber da ist schon zu spät. Der Teufel nimmt es und ist weg. Und da merkt man ja. Du kannst den Teufel ... Da ist die Lehre der Geschichte so, treibst du dich auf die Spitze ein bisschen. Ja. Ja, oder er ist halt in so einer Computersimulation
und er ist halt verbuggt oder so.
Daran sieht er, dass alles nur ein Programm ist,
weil er irgendwie, bei ihm ist der Code falsch
und er hat super viel Glück.
Also er hat halt einen Glückswert, normalerweise ist ein Mensch,
ein Glückswert fünf, manche sechs, manche vier.
Und er hat halt dreitausend Glück durch so einen Bug.
Und dadurch merkt er, dass das alles nur eine Computersimulation ist.
Aber niemand glaubt ihm. Aber dieser letzte Part ist nur so drei Zeilen und davor dieser Sex mit dem Huhn, der ist so in acht Kapiteln. Dieser schwitzige Hühnerstall, wo eh so wenig Platz ist und alles drängt aufeinander ein. Ausformuliert. Ah, fuu, huu, huu, Hot, hot, hot, hot, hot, hot, hot, hot, chicken wings, hot wings.
Wer von uns beiden könnte die? Ausformuliert. Hot, hot, hot, hot, hot, hot, hot, hot, chicken wings, hot wings.
Wer von uns beiden könnte die bessere ... Hot wings, heiße wings.
Hot, heiße.
Das ist die Kurzgeschichte.
Ja.
Finde ich nicht schlecht.
Wer von uns könnte die erotischere Kurzgeschichte schreiben?
Jetzt mal wirklich ernst.
Ich glaube ich.
Ja?
Ja.
Also wirklich so prickelnde Erotischere Kurzgeschichte schreiben. Jetzt mal wirklich ernst. Ich glaube ich. Ja? Ja. Also wirklich so prickelnde Erotik. Weiß ich nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Ich glaube, beide wären nicht die besten in Kurzgeschichten. Nee, glaube ich auch nicht. Nee, ich glaube, wir wären beide nicht so gut darin, aber ich glaube, ich könnte ein bisschen besser erotisch schreiben. Wollen wir mal jeder von uns, also ich glaube, also... Für diesen Podcast. Jeder von uns schreibt eine Erotik-Kurzgeschichte. Wir laden die beide auf so einer Erotik-Kurzgeschichten-Webseite hoch und wir schauen, wer nach einem Monat mehr Likes oder keine Ahnung, Sterne oder was auch immer hat. Also wer objektiv, ohne dass die Leute wissen, dass es von uns ist, unter Pseudonym. Das finde ich eine sehr gute Idee, ja. Und dann entscheidet sich ganz objektiv, wer von uns beiden der erotischere, sexy Autor ist. Es ist nicht ganz objektiv, ne? Weil je nachdem, wie skandalöser du bist und so und wie viel Glück du auch hast mit dem Veröffentlichungsdatum und wir laden es am gleichen Tag hoch, gleich zur gleichen Zeit wir sagen über niemandem, ja wir sagen niemandem welche Website oder was ja wow, es sind eh, wenn dann zwei es auf Englisch oder auf Deutsch Englisch dann, ne, was ist die prickelndste Sprache, ne, ich glaube deutsche Erotik-Websites glaube ich, zwei weirde Geschichten, die zur gleichen Zeit veröffentlicht wurden, habe ich halt Angst, dass man das dann entdeckt. Deswegen will ich lieber eigentlich ... Lesen wir denn auch vor? Nein. Können wir nicht machen. Was ich vorlesen will, ist die Kommentare. Oh ja, aber daran findet man es auch wieder. Aber hättest du ein Problem, dass ich deine Erotik-Geschichte lese? Bei mir wäre es ein bisschen unangenehm. Du darfst meinest meine Erotikgeschichte lesen. Ja, okay. Ja. Ich will, dass du sie liest. Und was habe ich dabei an? Das habe ich nichts an. Okay. Aber ich will, dass du sie liest. Ja. Okay. Wobei, dann kannst du auch nicht, du kannst nicht lügen, wenn sie dir gefällt. Ich verstehe, ich verstehe, was du meinst. Ich verstehe, was du meinst, ja. Das finde ich aber auch nicht schlecht. Als zweiten Test schließen wir zwei unvoreingenommene Leute ein. An so ein Pulsmesser. An so ein Pulsmesser. Bei welcher Geschichte der Puls? Und wir haben so ein Erektionsmesser. Ja, so ein Gratmesser. Ein Gratmesser. Ist natürlich die Frage jetzt, auf welche Zielgruppe gehst du? Würdest du die Geschichte anders schreiben, wenn du wüsstest, sie wird eher von Frauen gelesen oder eher von Männern? Oder glaubst du, es gibt so etwas wie eine universelle Erotik? Nee, erstmal würde ich, glaube ich, tief in die Forschung eindringen. Wie tief würdest du? Ich würde richtig tief und wahnsinnig verschwitzt in diese Forschung eindringen. Weil ich will erstmal wissen, werden diese Geschichten vor allem von Frauen gelesen oder eher von Männern? Dann will ich wissen, eher von heterosexuellen Menschen oder von homosexuellen Menschen. Ich möchte alles wissen und dann möchte ich quasi die Geschichte, die auf das perfekte Geschichtenlespublikum zugeschnittenes Schreiben. Um halt am meisten Chance zu haben, am meisten gelesen zu werden, um gegen dich zu gewinnen. Ich finde es spannend, ich finde es prickelnd, können wir machen. Wie lange ist denn so eine Geschichte? Puh, zwei Seiten. Was ist denn da so eine gute Länge? Zwei Minuten, oder? Ja, reicht. Zwei Minuten reicht. Eins, eins dreißig. Und dann ganz objektiv, weil du hast jetzt schon sehr sicher gewirkt, dass du mich schlagen kannst. Ich bin auch davon überzeugt, dass du vorne liegst, aber ich glaube, vielleicht kann ich als Underdog da noch was rausholen. Okay. Bin ich sehr gut, Deadline ist so in einem Jahr. Ja, absolut. Ich habe auch keine Zeit gerade. Ich muss leider auch los.
Deswegen ganz schlecht.
Deswegen machen wir nächste Woche weiter. Wir haben noch ein paar Sachen zu sagen.
Würde ich sagen. Macht's gut erst mal.
Schickt uns euer Wunder.
Das ist wichtig. Das machen wir wirklich.
Diesmal machen wir wirklich. Wir sagen oft sowas, aber das machen wir wirklich.
Haut rein, macht's gut und wir sehen uns
nächste Woche. Bis dahin. Wehm ab.
Wehm ab. Macht's gut und wir sehen uns nächste Woche. Bis dahin, weh, bap. Weh, bap, macht's gut. Ciao!